[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy tuesday there's
probably no institution in american life
that has more effect on how you live but
that we talk about less than the federal
reserve
people don't care to talk about the
federal reserve because it seems very
complex and a lot of what it does is in
fact complex unless you have a grounding
and monetary policy it's hard to know
exactly what's going on
but the basics aren't that complicated
actually and here are a few of them the
federal reserve was created way back in
1913 by an act of congress and it had
really two main goals
maximize employment and keep prices
stable keep inflation under control
those are virtuous goals
but it may be a measure of the way that
bureaucracies work that over time the
federal reserve has actively undermined
both of those objectives it's the
classic story of the firemen turned
arsonist or for that matter the covidzar
who helped create covid
irony of iron it seems like we read a
lot of those lately
in the case of the federal reserve
consider something called quantitative
easing that's the main thing the fed has
been doing since the financial crisis of
2008.
every month federal reserve officials
print more than 100 billion new dollars
in american currency and then they
inject those dollars into our financial
system by buying assets like bonds and
securities
this is not a normal thing to do it's a
radical thing to do and it was supposed
to be temporary it was in response to a
crisis
in medical terms quantitative easing is
like chemotherapy
there are times when it can save your
life but fundamentally it's poison if
you keep taking it it will kill you
pretty much everyone agrees on that and
pretty much everyone understands that
ultimately quantitative easing causes
horrible inflation and it's easy to
understand why you don't need to be an
expert
the more money you print the less that
money is worth it's supply and demand
you buy diamonds by the carrot but you
buy dirt by the yard overabundance
decreases value
so every new dollar you print buys less
if you keep printing them you wind up
devaluing your own currency
that's one thing a responsible
government should never do
it may enrich banks and a tiny number of
big investors who give to the democratic
party but devaluing your currency screws
everyone who works and who saves
and that's immoral
those are exactly the people that a
legitimate government ought to be trying
to help
as its core mission
and yet they're not
all these years later quantitative
easing continues they're still doing it
on wall street they joke about how it's
going to go on forever they call it qe
infinity
it's an incredibly reckless policy and
everybody knows it very much including
the people who are getting rich from it
so for the better part of a year fed
officials have been promising they're
going to stop doing this they have sworn
they will get sober they have vowed to
begin a process called tapering that
means they'll start to gradually slow
the money they print
at a fed meeting in april officials said
they'd start to do this very soon they
would taper but they never did
they made the same promise throughout
this summer but again
they didn't the binge continued
this morning the vice chairman of the
fed richard clarida once again insisted
that tapering is almost here we're about
to do it
the conditions to begin detox he said
have all but been met
and yet as of tonight the fed is still
partying with your currency like this is
the richest country in the world and
always will be
so what are the effects on our country
of this
well in the short term as with vodka it
makes everybody feel pretty good it's
3am your lips are numb and you can
barely see and yet somehow the breakfast
meeting downtown you've got in five
hours when you're gonna have to give a
detailed presentation to your boss
seems like no problem at all you've got
this
except you don't have it at all
morning always comes it is always worse
than you think
america's quantitative easing hangover
is going to be ugly
beneath the manufactured euphoria of our
top line economic numbers google's
killing it record profits for amazon
says cnbc
beneath all of that garbage
the actual american economy is in
trouble and there are many signs of it
labor markets are tight right now
because a lot of americans have simply
dropped out of the labor force
4.3 million people walked off the job
last month some of them were forced out
by joe biden's vaccine mandates
projections for gdp growth just dropped
from six percent to one and a half
percent
small businesses across the country are
dying
and maybe most ominous of all inflation
is here
it's not just a temporary problem caused
by cova disrupted supply chains it is
absolutely real
the american economy starting to sizzle
once again as it emerges from the
pandemic and workers paychecks are too
with businesses practically begging for
help but there's a flip side to all the
raises and that's inflation prices
rising at the fastest rate since 2008
everything from washing machines up
almost 30 percent to furniture up 11
percent and television sets up 8 percent
so it's happening throughout the economy
it's not just washing machines and
television sets consumer electronics
it's everything including the big things
try to buy a house it's now more
expensive to buy a home than it has ever
been at any time in american history the
median existing home price last year was
310 000 it's now over 356 000 and a lot
more in the zip codes you might want to
live in part of the reason is the cost
of building materials they're completely
out of control
last october lumber went for about 580
per thousand board feet as of last week
it was 712.
last august used cars which you might
need were selling for an average price
of 21 000. this august a year later they
were almost 28 000
same car
7 grand more
over the same period by the way as you
well know the price of gas jumped a full
dollar a gallon and a lot more than that
in some places
but in the grocery lately the cost of a
pound of steak is up by two bucks
a pound of bacon costs over seven
dollars right now
and suddenly everything costs more eggs
milk coffee mustard etcetera etcetera
etcetera these are not luxury items
this is not a trip to st barts these are
things you buy every week and you have
to buy
the question is
are your wages rising as fast as your
costs
well let's see vegetable oil is up 60
percent so probably not and that means
you're getting poorer whether you
realize it or not but that's what
inflation does it causes poverty
so because we can prove that the
population of the united states is
getting poorer by the day you'd think
the body administration would be
actively concerned about this and
working to make it better but they're
doing the opposite they're actively
making it much worse
and here's how they're doing it by
spending
no government in the history of the
world has ever spent more money than joe
biden is spending right now that is a
fact in fiscal year 2019 just the other
day the entire federal government spent
6.6 trillion dollars then covet hit the
following year and those numbers went up
they went up by 40
federal spending in 2020 jumped to 9.1
trillion was that too much of course it
was what do we get for it not enough
but here's the shocking thing
under joe biden as coveted recedes it's
going up even higher
because they're no longer using covid as
a pretext through the end of this august
which is to say a month and a half ago
the federal government has already spent
more in 2021 than it did over the entire
calendar years of 2019 and 2018.
so all of this drives inflation to scary
levels
but they're not scary to everyone if
you're a massively leveraged financial
institution that owes a lot of money to
a lot of people and that's how you're
making your money this is not
necessarily bad news if money is worth
less that means that your debt service
costs less
you don't fear inflation
inflation helps you the problem is it
crushes the american middle class
now in a normal country this would be a
huge concern
but because the people who make our
policy don't care about the middle class
this is a bargain well worth making
bloomberg news just published a piece
with this headline which we're not
making up they're celebrating the
disaster quote america needs higher
longer-lasting inflation
if you can even imagine writing
something like this does america need
more emphysema too it's grotesque
now most people may not know this is
happening normal people don't read
bloomberg news they may be unaware that
these attitudes even exist and what they
assumed was their country and the by
administration would like to keep it
that way would like to keep the
population from finding out what's
happening
so here's the treasury secretary janet
ellen she's the reptile who once ran the
federal reserve and is therefore more
responsible than any single living
person for your growing poverty
here she is assuring you that seven
dollar bacon isn't actually a problem
that's not really inflation it's
something called transitory inflation
i don't believe that we're at risk of
hyperinflation
we've had several months of high
inflation
that
most economists including me believe
will be transitory
as our economy gets back um
in full swing after the pandemic
it's just transitory it's the price of
progress seven dollar bacon yeah but
look what you're getting in return
aren't things great
until just a few hours ago that was the
official line in washington along with
those southwest delays were caused by
weather and our withdrawal from
afghanistan was actually a huge success
what are you talking about that's what
they were telling us
and then the president of the atlanta
fed a man called raphael bostic admitted
what was very obvious to anyone who goes
to the grocery store
this actually is inflation it is real
inflation it is not transitory inflation
and it's going to be here for a long
time what he didn't say was that this is
not an act of god this isn't a hurricane
it's not an earthquake it's not
something we can't control this is the
result of decades of policy that have
enriched a few
and impoverished the many
when will the reckoning be for that and
what are the effects for you going
forward hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else